الاف المعتقلات في السجون السوريه قدرتهم
المعارضه السوريه ب 13 الف معتقله الجزيره
تفتح ملف المعتقلات في سجون الاسد روايات
صادمه عن القتل والتعذيب معتقلات حوامل
بعضهن انجبن داخل السجون ترعرع اطفالهن
معهن ولم يتبقى امل في الخروج من الكهف
السوري امامهن الا عبر عمليه تبادل
المعتقلين والاسرى بين النظام والمعارضه
لكن حتى الناجيات ممن كتبت لهن حياه خارج
السجون ظللن يعانين من تحدي الاندماج في
مجتمع كان ولا يزال مشغولا بثورته عنهن
سنتابع قصه خرجت ولم تعد ونناقشها لاحقا
مع مدير الشبكه السوريه لحقوق الانسان فضل
عبد الغني ومن لبنان السجينه السوريه
السابقه مجد الشربجي ننوه الى اننا شرعنا
منذ ثلاثه ايام في تلقي مساهماتكم عبر
مختلف منصات التواصل الاجتماعي سنعرض ما
يرد منها خلال النقاش في حلقتنا هذه
امامكم الان على الشاشه ارقام للمشاركه
المرئيه اضافه الى الوسم الخاص بالحلقه
لكن مراكم الان ان نتابع قصه خرجت ولم
[موسيقى]
تعد
حالي بالمعتقل قدام
المحقق الحقيقه بسوريا نحن بنتعرض
للاختطاف طبعا اخذونا كل واحد لحاله
المعتقلين والمعتقلات
بموتوا تحت التعذيب اقسى لحظه هي لما نكون
عم نسمع تعذيب حدا تاني يعني هي اسوا
بمليون مره من انه تطلع تاكل ق يعني انا
ما بعرف ات ممكن يندق الباب او حتى مندون
ما يندق ينفتح وانا انحت
انه هذا المكان خلص هو القبر الابدي اللي
انا ممكن ابقى فيه بين ما الله ياخذ
امانته بعرف انه انا شغلي اكبر من هيك
صارت عام
2011 تاريخ سيغير وجه سوريا الى
الابد مدن كامله تنتفض على نظام حكم
البلاد على مدى عقود مستندا الى سسه القتل
والاقصاء والتهميش بحق من يجرؤ على معارضه
النظام
[تصفيق]
القائم قبل الثوره كان السوريون يدركون
تماما ان مصير من يعارض نظام الاسد سيكون
الموت او التغييب في ده الاقال
السياسي طل الملوحي هي احدى ضحايا النظام
قبل الثوره اعتقل طل عام 2009 وهي طالبه
في المرحله الثانويه وادين بتهمه التجسس
ومذاك وهي مخفيه قصرا رغم انتهاء مده
محكوميتها غيب الطل تماما ويرفض النظام
الكشف عن
مصيرها اعتقال طل اجابي فتره فعلا
كان كانت سياسه كم الافواه بسوريا طلعت
وقلت لانها حكيت وحكت بالوقت اللي ما كان
لازم تحكي فيه حكت بالوقت الغلط كتبت يعني
بهي الدوله اللي الكتابه فيها جريمه
التفكير جريمه الكلام جريمه وحتى الاحلام
جريمه اليوم طل مغيبه من وقت اللي كانت
بسجن عذرا وعلى اساس انه هي توقع اخلاق
سبيل وتم اقتيادها لفرع
ثاني ما حدا بيعرف شو مصيره ومع اتساع
رقعه المناطق الثائره لم يعد من فرق بين
شابه او شاب فقد تساوى الجميع في القهر
والاستهداف ومن ينجو من اقبيه المخابرات
والافرع الامنيه خبر قصصا مروعه عن
معتقلات
الموت فان تكون معارضا في سوريا يعني ان
تستعد في كل لحظه تمتد اليك يد
الاختطاف يد كما تطال الرجال فهي تطال
النساء ايضا لا احد خارج دائره الخطر
اعتقال كان ب
20 اجا فرع الامن السياسي بطرطوس انا كنت
بطرطوس بحكم انه نحن كنا عم نتنقل داخل
سوريا لانه الوضع الامني كان بحمصه صالح
للعيش دوره الامن السياسي اللي عننا على
البيت سلمتهم جهاز الايسر هو كان فاضي كان
التبليغ دقيق جدا لدرجه انه عرفانيه عندي
جهاز ثاني
توشيبا قالوا طلبوا مني انه يجيبه طبعا
انا كثير تلبكت لانه بعرف حالي انه خلص
انا
يعني رحت فيها يعني انا عرفاني حالي انه
على جهاز التوشيبا ما كان فاضي وانا كنت
عم حاول اخبيه ما طالع برات البيت كنت
يعني ناشطه بالمجال المدني من بدايه
الثوره شاركنا بالمظاهره والاعتصامات
ولهالسبب اعتقلت ب 31/12 201012 بعد ما
صارت احداث داريه الاخيره وهجروا كل اهل
المدينه منا فدخلت انا لداريا كنت عم اعمل
تحقيق صحفي عن المشفى الميداني ل جريده
عنب بلدي بهي الاثناء كان في اساسا هو
اشتباك ما بين الشباب اللي بالمعظمة
قلين معي بنفس الغرفه اللي على الحاجز فبي
جوا الجيش الحر تبع المعظم وبصير في
اشتباك قوي
بين بين العناصر الموجودين على الحاجز
والجيش الحر بصير ضربه كثير و يعني لدرجه
انه يعني الرصاص صار فوق راسنا عم عم
يمر نحن لما بنحكي للراي العام العالمي عن
تجربه الاعتقال دائما الفكره انه في شرطي
بلباس انيق بيجي بيدق الباب مع مذكره
توقيف بتهمه واضحه ل بتوضيح للعائله
وللشخص نفسه انه هو وين رايح لكن الحقيقه
بسوريا نحن بنتعرض للاختطاف انا مثلا كنت
ب بباص بولمن طالعه من مدينه دمشق الى
مدينه حلب وفعلا تم اختطافي من اشخاص
مجهولين تم اقتياده لجهه مجهوله اي معصوبه
العينين
مربط الايدي كانوا بلباس مدني بسياره
مدنيه كمان
فكل يعني كل المشهد كان يوحي بانه مشهد
عصابه عم
تختطف مجرد انه يسمعوا داريه انه انت من ر
يعني بلش الضرب ما اعرف كيف الكفوف يعني
عم عم تجيني ببطن العسكري يضربوني على وشي
كذا بعد الضرب وهيك بطوني بالسياره
بيقولوا لي
انه كم انه اعتقلنا زوجك فانا بتوقع انه
تكون مسحه يعني مشان يخوفوني وكذا و
وبالفعل يعني بسمع بعدين صوت زوجي لانه
كنت انا مطم مشه
وبيحطو بحطوا زوجي بالطبع السياره ورا
وانا بال قدام وبينزلو على مطار المز
[موسيقى]
الجويه يوجد ثلاث مراحل للاعتقال في سوريا
يوجد مرحله الاعتقال الاول اللي هي
اسوا المراحل والعدد قليل جدا من
المعتقلين والمعتقلات يخرجوا من اقبيه
الافرع الامنيه المراحل الاولى يتم
الاعتقال في الفروع الامنيه ومن ثم يتم
تحويل معتقلين او من تبقى منهم عمه معظم
للاسف يعني المعتقلين والمعتقلات
بيموتوا تحت
التعذيب
سيدي خلاص في ش شو هيك
صغيره بات ثابتا لدى الناشطين السوريين ان
النظام يوسع من اعداد النساء المعتقلات
لديه حتى ولو لم يشاركن في النشاط السياسي
بهدف الضغط على
عائلاتهن كما يعمد النظام الى فرض عقاب
جماعي على اهالي بلدات ومدن ثائره فيتولى
الامن مهمه اعتقال الاعداد الاكبر من
السكان وهنا ايضا النساء لسنا
استثناء طبعا العدد مهول عدد كثير كبير من
النساء وفي منهم تت 18 جايبينهم بتهم كثير
سخيفه
انه تنزيل طيارات عن طريق الدوشكا انه
طفله هالقد بدها تنزل طياره من عن طريق
الدوشكا وقت
اللي خبروها انه هي بد تروح على المحكمه
وعرضوها قدام القاضي القاضي صار يضحك
واغلب النساء اللي كانوا موجودين يعني ما
لهم علاقه يعني اكثر النساء هن فعلا يعني
للا لهم مؤيدين ول لهم معارضين يعني ما
لهم علاقه بالشيء ابدا يعني نسبه 1% هن
كانوا فع مشتغلين مثلي يعني اكتشفتوا انه
كثير من النساء المتواجد يعني اساسا كثير
من النساء المعتقلات ما لهم علاقه اذا بدك
باي بالثوره او بالوضع السياسي يعني
اعتقلوهم يا اما ضغط على احد اقربائهم
الاخ بيكون مثلا بالمعارضه
المسلحه الام كذا فانه عم عم عم
[موسيقى]
يضغطوا كثير قابلت نساء مثلا لما تحولت
بعد ال الفرع الامني على السجن المركزي
كانوا نساء بالسبعينات من عمرهم معتقلات
فقط لانهم هن من منطقه الحوله في سيده
كانت مريضه قلب وعندها كثير مشاكل صحيه تم
اعتقالها فقط لانها من الرستم كل ه
المناطق غير الصبايا من داريا ومن دوما
ومن المناطق الثائره كان دائما عم يتم
الانتقام على
الهويه
الرقم الموثق الاكثر دقه الذي نتكلم عنه
عندما نتكلم عن الاعتقال نتكلم عن 230 ال
معتقل لكن لاكون دقيق نحن نتكلم هون عن
الاعتقال السياسي وكن ايضا يوجد في سوريا
ملف جدا صعب وهو ملف الاختفاء القصري
والارقام المختفين قصريه يتجاوز ايضا ال
140 ال مختفي قصريه في بعض المحافظات
السوريه التي تخضع الان لسيطره النظام اما
ارقام المختفين قصريه والمعتقلين في
الشمال السوري وفي المناطق التي تخضع
للمعارضه السوريه نتكلم عن حوالي 8000
مختفي قصريه المناطق التي تحت سيطره داعش
لا يوجد ارقام يوجد تخمينات والتخمينات
تتكلم عن حوالي 23000 مختف اليه التاكد هي
فقط انه يطلع حدا من المعتقلين او
المعتقلات داخل
هذا الفرع شاهد هذا الشخص وقدر ياخذ رقم
تليفون او وسيله تواصل يروح يسبر اهله
الحديث عن مراحل الاعتقال والانتهاكات
التي تتعرض لها المعتقلات المعارضات
للنظام يشي بوجود سياسه منتجه في مراكز
الاعتقال وسجون المخابرات لانها المعتقله
جسديا ونفسيا وعقليا على حد سواء
بطرطوس فرع الامن
السياسي طبعا اخذونا كل واحد لحاله انا
واخي وامي
وابي صار تحقيق كل واحد لحاله عم يحاولوا
كانوا انه يعني يوقعوا حدا
بيناتنا انا بعرف حالي انه انا مشتغله
يعني للثوره و مشتغله كان عندي كنا بتنسيق
بحمص قلتله انه انا عندي على اللاب توب
هيك هيك هيك فيكم تشوفوا اهلي ما لهم خبر
بال باللي عم يصير كان كانوا يجوا ياخذوني
من الغرفه الساعه 12 بالليل وي يدوروا
فيني بمطار المزع يعني مثل عذاب نفسي وطول
الوقت يقولوا لي اه وقعتي وما حدا سمع
عليك اكتشفنا شو عم تشتغلي يعني وتهديدات
وحكي ف بدهم يكان يعرفوا مني وين بيصنعوا
العبوات الناس فين وين وين مقرات الجيش
الحر وهحكي هذا فقال له انا انه ناشطه
سلميه يعني انا ما لي علاقه بموضوع السلاح
وهي انا وقت اللي استقبلوني يعني
كانت الشتائم وال الحكي اللي يعني لا يليق
لا ب انثى ولا باي كائن
بشري طبعا بيلعبوا كثير على الوتر العرض
والشرف والعادات والتقاليد طبعا شافوني
انا وحده مثلا محجبه لابس لبس مثلا محتشم
نوعا ما
كثير اشتغلوا على الوتر الليي هو ممكن انه
يخليني مثلا اتنرفز او كثير عصب حتى ممكن
انه ياخذوا مني حكي 35 يوم لحتى عرفت انه
انا موجوده بفرع فلسطين قبل كنت موجوده
بمكان
بيشبه بس جدران مرتفعه بدون
اي بدون اي نوافذ حتى واو بدون اي صله مع
مع دوره اليوم من حيث انه هلا ليل او نهار
كان احس انه هذا المكان خلص هو الاقبر
الابدي اللي انا ممكن ابقى فيه بين ما
الله ياخذ
[موسيقى]
امانته اكدت المنظمات الحقوقيه ان تحويل
المعارضات للمحاكمات لا يتم الا بعد وقت
طويل من تاريخ الاعتقال
الفعلي اضافه الى ان كثيرات يفارقنا
الحياه تحت التعذيب ولا يتم ابلاغ
عائلاتهن بذلك
بحسب افادات معتقلات ناجيات من سجون
النظام فان المحاكمه لا تعني ان مراحل
التعذيب النفسي والجسدي قد
انتهت وتقول نساء معارضات تعرضن للاعتقال
ان المعاناه الاطول تبدا عند ايداعه في
السجون سجن طرطوس طبعا كانت المعامله كثير
سيئه انه انا من سياسه كانوا كثير يخافوا
من ه الفكره بعرف انه انا الشغله اكبر من
هيك صارت بما انه انا اي تكمش معي مثلا
ملفات معينه ما كان الامر بهالسهوله انه
انا اطلع من الفرق اول اسبوع زمان كان
التعذيب جدا يعني تشبي شبحي مرتين يعلوني
بالسقف
وضرب ما في رحمه يعني لا نساء ولا رجال
عندهم يعني اخر شيء مره بعد ما ضربني كثير
بالعصايه هي احد المرات يعني فبيقول لي
انه بحسك السؤال اذا جاوبتي عليه بتركك
يعني قلت له شو قال كم ولد عندك قلت له
ثلاثه قال لي اولادك انت متاكده انه هدول
من زوجك يعني سؤال [__] يعني فقلت له ليك
اذا عم تسالني متوقع مني جاوب مالي راح
جاوب برجع اكفي ضربك اذا بدك يعني اقسى
لحظه هي لما نكون عم نسمع تعذيب حدا ثاني
هي فعلا اقسى من لحظات التعذيب على الشخص
نفسه بتذكر في شب من من حوران من من نوا
اي بقوا خمس ايام عم يعذبوه بس مشان يعطي
اسم اعلامي قريه مجاوره لكن هو رفض
وبالاخر سكت صوته يمكن استشهد تحت التعذيب
ما بعرف بالكامل في مساواه ما بين الرجل
والمراه باساليب التعذيب يمكن بالبدايات
ما كان في هذا الشيء
موجود لكن على التطورات الميدانيه
والتطورات السوريه كان النظام عم ينحى
اكثر
للخيار
الدموي الخيار الدموي ما كان بفرق بين جسد
الرجل وجسد المراه ولا حتى جسد
الطفل وثقت الشبكه السوريه لحقوق الانسان
نحو
12679 شخصا لقوا حتفهم في سوريا بسبب
التعذيب خلال خمس سنوات مبينه ان 99 في
منهم قضوا على يد قوات النظام السوري
بطرطوس تبلغت ان انه انا راح
اكون
مع المركب اللي راح يروح على الشام على
محكمه
الارهاب طبعا كان الخبر كثير صادم انه انا
يعني خلص رح تكون رحلتي كثير طويله بال
الافع والله العليم شو راح يكون تعامل
الافرع الباقيه معي يعني ممكن انا نفذت
بالفرع الاولاني من الضرب ممكن يكون اللي
بعده يعني ممكن انا اموت يعني بكل بساطه
ما عندهم حاجز او او احترام للجسد بعد
اسبوع من من الاعتقال تم نقلي من فرع رجع
لفرع ثاني داخل مطار المزل العسكري هي اخر
مره بشوف فيها زوجي نقلونا سوا كان كثير
معذبين يعني وكان ما يعني مثل مغمى عليه ف
بالزور يعني لحتى رد علي بكم كلمه يعني
انه عم اساله كيفك ف بس قال لي الحمد لله
وبس هي يعني بعدها ما عاد شفته قال لهم
خذوها طبعا انا الرعب اللي كنت عايشته كان
لا يوصف انا مااني عرف حالي لوين رايحه
نزلونا على السراديب لتحت طبعا عتمي ما في
ضو الريحه بتقرف
وشوف عالم عم تطل عليك من من الشباك تبع
الباب يختصر السجن بانه هو مصادره لانسان
الشخص اللي موجود
فيه لو كنا عم نحكي عن عن سجن بظروف
انسانيه اما ظروف الافرع الامنيه بسوريا
فهي حتى بالحيوانات
لاطلق تحرم المعتقلات تماما من اي رعايه
صحيه ويخضع خلال فترات الاعتقال لتعذيب
نفسي مستمر والاصعب بحسب شهادات معتقلات
سابقات هو العزل الكامل عن
المحيط يتركنا لفترات طويله دون تحقيق لا
يسمعنا سوى صراخ معتقلات يعذبنا ولا يتنفس
سوى رائحه الدم بشوف جسس لما نمشي بالكرد
ولات ب نطلع على الحمام نشوف جساس ملح وشه
على الكريول يعني كنا نحن زنزانه ابدا
مترين بمترين يعني بالضبط يعني لانه عديت
البلاطات يعني تبعيتها غالب الناس اللي
برا او هذا بفكروا انه مشكله المعتقل جوا
هي بس انه والله عم يعذبوه ويقتلوه بشكل
فعلي هي مو هون يعني المعاناه الاكبر هي
كيف عم عم يقضي ايامه اذا بدك بالمعتقل
بزنزانة الباب او حتى مندون ما يندق ينفتح
وانا ان شحت من جوا كل نهار يعني ظل قاعده
لا ادر نام لاظل لا اقدر اعمل اي شيء ممكن
انه ينعمل جوا بس قاعده عم استنى الباب او
اسمع بس المفاتيح تبع الباب حتى اكون يقزه
حتى ما انه يغافل وي او انا انا ونايمه او
انا عم بعمل اي شيء كانت الحياه تختصر
بريحه الدم ريحه صد الحديد الاصوات تختصر
بفتح قفل الزنزانه واغلاقها باصوات التع
ذيب بصوت الصوت بصوت الكهرباء هي وعمها
تضرب ما فينا نعرف اخبار من برا الا عن
طريق اللي يجي حدا جديد يعني انه المعتقل
اي معتقل يجي جديد من برا ف نحطه استجواب
اذا بدك يعني كان معتقل لما يجينا من برا
ننبسط للحظه انه استجواب انه شو عم يصير
شو صاير كانوا يجيبوا لنا
جبنه مثلثات الجبنه بقى نحاول انه نلف
الصدره نحاول نرسم على الحيطان نكتب هيك
قصص شغلات وكنا نحاول نقرا ش في موجود على
الحيطان كنت اتمنى على طول انه يكون معي
كاميرا اقدر اصور الاشياء اللي كانت
موجوده جوا ولاجل السخريه الاشخاص يلي كنت
اقرا اسمائهم على على الحيطان كنت التقى
فيهم بسجن عذرا يعني هي مثل اشبه برحله
يعني الواحد لازم يمر على كذا فرع حتى انه
مثل عم يوثق حالته او شيء يعني حااول انه
يترك بصمه انه انا هون يعني انا مريت لهون
برغم البشاعه بس انه انا لا انا مريت
لهون وتوثق نساء جون من الاعتقال لحظات
قاسيه شهدنا فيها موتى سيدات حوامل بسبب
تعقيدات الولاده وغياب الرعايه الصحيه اما
الاقصى فهو موت اطفال حدث الولاده في
اقبيه المخابرات ومراكز الاعتقال في نساء
ماتوا بسجن عذرا وفي اطفال ماتوا بسجن
عذرا والاطفال اللي مع امهاتهم كمان احد
العزبت هو الاطفال المسجونين مع امهاتهم
كثير هذا انا بحسه انه يعني شو ز وهذا
الطفل لحتى قاعد هيك قاعده يعني انه في
شيء اهات كانوا حوامل ولد هنك كمان بال
بالمعتقل يعني انه هذا الولد فتح عينه لقى
حاله قعد
[موسيقى]
بزنزانة النظام الامل الوحيد للافراج عن
النساء المعتقلات وفي شهادات لناجي افرج
عنهن خلال التفاوض فان عمليات اختيار من
يفرج عنهن تتم بشكل
عشوائي تختاروا خمس بنات من الغرفه من اصل
بنت تحت مسمى التسويه وليس العفو العفو
ممكن انه تمسح ا ادبنا كامله بس التسويه
طبعا هي تسويه اوضاع مؤقته انا بدي اض على
تواصل مع الفرع بتذكر اول شي عملته اني
انا نزلت على الارض ومسكت
التراب لما مسكت التراب وقتها حسيت انه
انا ما قعدت بالسجن كنت محتاجه اتاكد زوجي
ما بعرف عن شي وقت لي يعني انتقلنا من فرع
المهام اللي بالمطار المزل لفرع التحقيق
شفته هي اخر مره وبعدين ما كنت اسعد عنه
على طول وكذا ما في اي جواب يعني بعد ما
طلعت من المعتقل شي خمس شهور هو استشهد
بال بالمعتقل بس ما سلموني اغراضه لب شيء
تسع شهور يعني عن طريق واسطه وكذا لا قدرت
انه اعرف اتاكد يعني من من استشهاده بعد
ما طلعنا من السجن طبعا حطوا لنا ختم على
الكف هون انه انت طلعت مثل المداجن يعني
انه طلعت انت من محكمه الارهاب شفت بنات
عندهم الرغبه انه ما يوقعوا على ورقه
اخلاء السبيل وما يدفعوا على الكفاله مشان
ما يطلعوا يواجهوا
المجتمع تقول معتقلات الناجيات ان اصعب
المراحل بعد الافراج عنهن هي محاوله
الاندماج من جديد في البيئه
الاجتماعيه محاولات قد لا تنجح في الغالب
بسبب غياب برامج الدعم النفسي والتاهيل من
التعذيب وقائع قاسيه وقصص تحد وبقاء تخبر
عنها سوريات قهرنا الجلاد
ورغم انهن
افلتني الا ان معاناتهن لا تنتهي بالافراج
عنهن انا ما بحس حالي اني تصرفت شي غلط
يعني
هو الوضع اللي كان صاير هو اللي كان غلط
التحدي الاكبر لما ها المراه لا بتلاقي
دعم نفسي ولا بتلاقي دعم اجتماعي حاله
النبذ الاجتماعي او حاله اللوم الاجتماعي
اللي عم تشوفها النساء واللي عم تكون
ضحيتها هي عم تدخل بحالات نفسيه وانكسارات
اكبر بكثير من لو كان هذا المجتمع هو
محتضن انا اول ما دخلت على المعتقل يعني
بداخلي كنت عم اقول انه هي بالنسبه لي مثل
تجربه او مثل امتحان يعني يا بنجح ف يا
برسب لانه كثير من الناس اللي دخلوا على
المعتقلات
يطلعوا كثير مغيرين نقطه التغيير الاساسيه
بتبدا من المجتمع لما المجتمع بغير
افكاره بغير سلوكياته فبالتالي بغير
الظروف للاحسن لدعم هؤلاء
[موسيقى]
النساء سوريات قهرنا الجلاد بدايه اود ان
اشكر نيابه عن كل اعضاء الفريق هؤلاء
النساء الشهدات اللواتي ادلين بشهادتهن في
موضوع ليس من السهل دائما الحديث عنه في
مجتمعاتنا نرحب مجددا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
نذكر بان نواصل تلقي ارائكم واسئلتكم بشان
موضوع حلقتنا عبر حسابنا على تويتر
وصفحتنا على موقع فيسبوك مره اخرى ايضا
نرحب بضيفي الكريمين في الاستوديو مدير
الشبكه السوريه لحقوق الانسان فضل عبد
الغني ومن لبنان السجينه السوريه السابقه
مجد الشوربجي والتي تابعنا طبعا شهادتها
في الفيلم
سيد فضل يعني هذه الايام تتزامن
مع بث هذه الحلقه ذكرى مجزره حماه
التاريخيه سنه 1982 والتي ذهب ضحيتها حسب
مصادر عديده قربه ال 4 الف سوري المدن
السوريه للاسف وما اكثرها شبيه بحماه
ماساه تتكرر ما اود ان اسالك عنه عن
المعلومات التي تحتكم عليها في منظمتكم
بخصوص هذا الموضوع موضوع حلقتنا الليله
المتعلق بال معتقلات اعدادهم ظروف
احتجازهن اماكن وجغرافيه تواجدهن ايضا في
الارض وفي السجون السوريه للنظام
السوري طبعا هذا الموضوع هو من اعقد
المواضيع واكثرها تشابكا في الثوره
السوريه طبعا حماه هناك بين 40 ل 500 الف
هو جرح غائر وايضا هناك 177000 مفقود وما
زال مفقود حتى الان يعني نفس السيناريو
قتل و واعتقال قال ثم مفقودين نفس
السيناريو ما يحصل في الثوره السوريه يعني
نحن بدانا بتسجيل حالات الاعتقال وبشكل
يومي هناك يعني فريق يعمل ويقوم
بشفت الداتا بشكل يومي ثم بشكل شهري وهناك
عمليات تدقيق وعمليات فلتره اذا هي ليست
الارقام هي يعتقد ربما بعض الناس انه هي
ارقام تقديريه هناك ارقام تقديريه لكن
عندما يصدر عن الشبكه السوريه لحقوق
الانسان هي ارقام
حقيقيه وهي ارقام موجوده ولدينا داتا وهذه
الداتا هي هذه هذه الموثقه نعم بالدليل
بالاسم بالشهاده بالصوره
ب ولهذا نحن نقول انها هي الحد الادنى اما
التقديرات ربما البعض يقدرها بضعفين او
ثلاثه او ثلا هذه المعلومات التي توصلتم
اليها انتم فقط في الشبكه السوريه لحقوق
الانسان ن ن نحن فقط ضمن المعايير التي
نتبعها انه نسمع شخص او شخصين ونقاط
المعلومات ونسج نجلها ونقوم بتخزينها عبر
وماذا تقول هذه المعلومات في عجاله
للمشاهد الكريم نعم المعلومات تقول انه في
عننا تقريبا 14000 معتقله في سوريا طبعا
النظام تقريبا عنده القسم الاعظم مثل ما
اشار التقرير هو المنتهك الاكبر لانه هو
بدا من بدايات الثوره السوريه يعني كان
هناك حاله واحده هي النظام هي السائده او
طرف واحد خلينا نقول هو الم وحش وامتد
بعدين دخلت اطراف اخرى دخلت الميليشيات
الشيعيه اصبحت طرف دخلت اطراف في المعارضه
تنظيمات مطرفه هذا دخل بعد سنوات النظام
هو لديه تقريبا
8400 معتقله بيناتهم 300 طفله دون سن دون
سنه ال 18 هذول ما زالوا حتى الان نحن ما
عم نتكلم عن اللي خاضوا تجربه الاعتقال
يعني عن اللي دخلوا وعن اللي طلعوا هذول
هن اللي ما زالوا
طبعا تقريبا من ال 8000 عننا تقريبا 2000
و400 هول ما بنعرف عنهم اي معلومه يعني
هون في وقت بنقول نحن نتحدث عن الاعتقال
لكن نتحدث ايضا عن الاختفاء القصري عن
الاختفاء القصري الاختفاء القصري مش بس
انه نحن ما بنعرف معلومه نحن حتى لو عرفنا
معلومه والجهه اللي معتقله النظام يعني
بموجب القانون الدولي الانساني يتحدث انكر
وجودها عنده ما مهم انه نحن نعرف المهم
هون ونقطه الفصل انه هو اللي انكر وهو
مانكر انه وجود اغلب المعتقلين والمعتقلات
عنده ولهيك نحن بنقول انه اغلب المعتقلين
والمعتقلات في سوريا هم مختف مختفون قسريا
اي و وهم اشاره استفهام وهي الرساله هو
النظام بده يقوم فيها هذا الهدف الاساسي
نحن سمعنا بتقرير انه في ناس ما لها اي
علاقه ليش يعني شو الهدف الهدف هو تفتيت
الحاضنه الاجتماعيه وتحطيم المجتمع وشله
بشكل يعني دراما دراماتيكي ليؤدي الى
ايقاف واخماد هي ممتاز هذه نقطه مهمه تشير
اليها بانه هناك من من بين المعتقلين
والمعتقلات ايضا من ليس له علاقه اطلاقا
بالموضوع سمعنا بعض الشهادات ايضا في
الفيلم بهذا الخصوص اتحول السيده مجد من
خلال تجربتك انت في سجون النظام وفي
الاعتقال من خلال معاينات ايضا هل لك ان
تحدثينا عن تجارب من هذا النوع اطراف تم
اعتقالها وليس لها لا ناقه ولا جمل في
موضوع الثوره السوريه على ماذا تم
الاعتقال سمعنا احدى الشهدات تتحدث عن
اعتقال بحسب المنطقه داريه الحوله الرستن
مناطقه اخرى ما الذي يمكن ان تقوليه
كشهاده ايضا تودين ان تضيفيها على ما قلته
في
الفيلم صحيح
تماما يعني غالبيه المعتقلات خلينا نقول
ما يقارب 90% اللي انا قابلتهم بالسجون
هن ما لهم علاقه بالاحداث اللي عم تصير
وانما هن يعني نساء من مناط ناطق سائره
والنظام كان عم يحاول يعتقلهم من اجل
الضغط على زويهم لحتى يسلموا انفسهم او
حتى مثل ما
قال س انه كرمال يصير في تفكك اكبر
ويوقفوا عن عن اكمال المسير طبعا وفي احد
الحالات يلي هي
قريبتي رشا شربجي كان بدهم زوجها فتم
اعتقالها هي وثلاث اطفال وهي حامل بتوام
ولدت في السجن وحاليا هي مغيبه ما حدا
بيعرف عنها اي شيء والخمس اطفال هم
الموجودين بالميتم وهي احد الاشياء يلي
الى حد ما مغيبه انه في كثير من الاطفال
يلي مو غير الموجودين بالمعتقلات مع
امهاتهم في جزء من الاطفال موجودين في
المياتم مع النظام السوري وما عم يقبل ولا
باي شكل يسلمهم لاقاربهم او لذويهم وعم
يتم وحتى بواسطت كبيره جدا لحتى يقدروا
اهاليهم يزوروه يعني اقربائهم بيت جدهم
يقدروا يزوروا هي الاطفال
ا يعني وعم يتم تربيتهم اسوا تربيه واسوا
معامله هي كمان احد المشاكل فالقسم الكبير
جدا هو اللي ما له علاقه واللي عم يتم
اعتقاله فقط للضغط على على
زويهم في بس بتذكر انه في احد السيدات
اعتقلوها كان معها على الحجز قطرميز مقدوس
فقالوا لها انه هذا القطرميز اكيد اخذتيه
للجيش الحر وتم اعتقاله وضلت تسع شهور في
المعتق نوع من الغذاء فقط
الش جدا يعني سخيف
اها تمام تماما هو نوع من الغذاء ف يعني
لحتى انه لاسباب كثير سخيفه كان يتم
اعتقال النساء وهو ايضا انا بعتبر انه
كرمال اذا في حال صار اي حاله تبادل فهو
بيطلع هالن سء احسن ما يطلع رجال هن يعني
لهم قيمتهم بالثوره ه الناشطين السلميين
المتواجدين في السجون من خمس ست سنوات ففي
حال صار اي مبادره
مع اسرى ف باخرج قسم من هي السيدات يلي هن
ما لهم علاقه باي عمل او
باي شغل سياسي طبعا تبقين معنا سيده مجد
دعونا نتوقف ربما مع الهدف البعيد من
اشكال هذا التعذيب الوحشي الذي يتعرض له
المعتقلون والمعتقلات بسجون الاسد والذي
تكشفه لنا هذه المدونه المرئيه التي ساهم
بها المدون السوري ابراهيم العلبي نتابع
شهد بنفسي في ظرف شهرين ونصف مقتل اربعه
معتقلين في فرع فلسطين تحت التعذيب او
الاهمال الصحي المتعمد هذا في 2009 فما
بالك اليوم هنا لابد لنا ان ندرك ان
التعذيب الوحشي الممنهج في سجون الاسد ليس
مجرد وسيله للتحقيق مع المعتقلين
والمعتقلات ولا حتى مجرد انتقام سادي
غرائزي بل هو بالاضافه الى كل ذلك وسيله
ارهاب نفسي يقصد النظام تصديرها الى
المجتمع ليكون جزءا من حربه على الشعب تلك
الحرب الهادفه لاطفاء ما امكنه من ارادته
المشتعله مره اخرى اعود اليك ضيفنا الكريم
سيد فضل يعني ما نود ان نعرفه سمعنا
الكثير من المواضيع فيما يخص ظروف
الاعتقال هناك من يتحدث عن خطف عصابات خطف
بزي مدني وبسيارات مدنيه نود ان نعرف ايضا
ما الذي يقوله القانون الدولي بخصوص ما
يتم الان وما يجري الان في سوريا والذي
توثق على نطاق واسع كمنظمات
حقوقيه عندما تعرضون على المجتمع الدولي
يعني استاذه فيروز نحن تجوزا نقول او
تجاوزا او تجوزا نقول كلمه اعتقال وليس
اعتقال الاعتقال هناك شروط انه يكون في
مذكره توقيف ويكون هناك معروف السبب ويكون
اي يكشف مصيره ويسمح انه هو محامي هيك هي
كلمه هذا التعريف او المصطلح اما هو
بسوريا بوقف على الحاجز بيتم اخذه ما
بيعرف وين رايح اهله ما بيعرفوا وينه ما
بحق له يوكل محامي وهذا حال يعني نحن فيني
اقول انا انه ما مر لعنا ولا حاله واحده
من بين يعني عشرات الالاف يعني
هق ما مر ولا حاله واحده انه هناك مذكره
اعتقال واحده ولا حتى الحالات المشهوره
للسياسيين او غيرهم او ما الى ذلك كله
بيتم اقتحام الابواب اذا راحوا على بيته
او بيتم اخذهم من المعتقل هذا حاله
الاعتقال اذا هو نحن تجوزا بنقول انه هو
اعتقال
تعسفي مثل ما قلت لك لكن اللي عم يجري ما
بعد الاعتقال ها كلها وصفتها لجنه التحقيق
الدوليه انه هي جرائم ضد الانسانيه
التعذيب وقد ووثقتم انتم بان 99% من حالات
الموت تحت التعذيب يقوم بها ومسؤول عنها
النظام السوري بحسب الداتا اللي نحن عننا
نحن عننا في عده اطراف فنحن دائما ب بنشوف
انه مين بنحط النسب والتناسب سواء بالقتل
او بالتعذيب او بالاعتقال فبي اختلف
التعذيب هو النظام ليش لانه هو عنده العدد
الاكبر من المعتقلين ومن المعتقلات فهو
وهي النقطه الاولى النقطه الثانيه انه هو
عنده مثل ما ذكرنا هو حتى من قبل الثوره
من ايام حما ومن غير حما هي ومازال متبعها
حتى الان يعني بين استطالات بين قوسين
الان هناك في وقف لاطلاق النار بسوريا لكن
ميكانزم التعذيب هي متواصله هي الميكانزم
هي منفصله تماما عن عمليات القصف والتدمير
والتشريد وتغير هي دائما موجوده وهي عم
تؤدي للوفيات بسبب التعذيب للاسف الشديد
سيده مجد مره اخرى اود ان نسمع منك بخصوص
شهادتك ما الاصعب في الاعتقال التعذيب
النفسي الجسدي العقلي سمعنا احدى الشهدات
تتحدث حتى ان صوت مفاتيح السجان قد تشكل
ضغطا نفسيا على المعتقلات
طبعا هو يعني التعذيب الجسدي هو بيكون صعب
بس بفتره يعني بوقت التعذيب و بس التعذيب
النفسي هذا مستمر دائما طول فتره الاعتقال
لانه اكثر شيء هو بعذب نفسيا الغموض عدم
معرفه مصير مصيره
الواحد كان ال يعني من سياسه النظام هو
تضييع العالم يعني المعتقلين فكانوا
يعتقلوا اثنين بنفس التهمه شخص يطلع بعد
شهرين وشخص لهلا مغيب هي احد سياساتهم
بشوف انا اول شيء لحتى الاشخاص يخونوا
بعضهم البعض ويشككون ببعضهم البعض وبنفس
الوقت هي لحتى يضيع المعتقلين يلي يلي
موجوده بالسجون انه ما يعرفوا هم بالضبط
يعني شو مصيرهم انه او يقدروا يعطوا توقع
لحالهم انه ههم قامت قد يخرجوا من ال من
المعتقل فطبعا الوضع النفسي كثير يعني
كثير سيء اي اصوات التعذيب يلي بنسمعها
انا بالنسبه لي كان هو اسوا شيء حاله
العجز يلي بتصير عننا حيال الاصوات يلي
بنسمعها بشكل يعني بكل دقيقه وبكل ثانيه
ونحن ما عم نقدر نعمل اي شيء هي كمان احد
ال يعني
ال التعذيب النفسي
ذكر ضيفنا الكريم هنا بان اعداد المعتقلات
اللواتي خرج منجون النظام السوري وانت
واحده منهن هو عدد قليل جدا وبالتالي
السؤال اي مسؤوليه تقع على عاتقكم انتم
انتن عفوا لربما ايصال صوت المعتقلات وما
يعانين في سجون النظام السوري خاصه وان
المجتمع الدولي يبدو كمن يصم الاذان عن
هذه الم التي يتجاوب ربما معها في مناطق
اخرى من
العالم بصراحه يعني مثل ما ذكر السيد فضل
هو العدد القليل يلي خرج من من السجون
والعدد القليل جدا جدا يلي هن كان عندهم
وعي انه يوصلوا ما راوا في السجون لانه
اغلب النساء يلي عم تخرج من السجون هي عم
تخرج خائفه جدا المجتمع ما عم يرحم فهي ما
بدها تحكي اي شيء عن عن موضوع اعتقالها
طبعا المجتمع الدولي متخاذل جدا لابعد
الحدود مع قضيه المعتقلين يلي انا اعتبرها
هي قضيه
انسانيه وما فيها شوائب واكثر يعني انا
درت رحت على جنيف مرتين كرمال قضيه
المعتقلين وثاني مره خبرتهم انه انا بعرف
انه هم ما حيعملوا اي شيء بس انا اجيت
وحكيت فقط لحتى يسجل التاريخ
وانه وصلنا على اراضيهم وحكينا شو اللي
كان شو عم يصير بالسجون وهن ن شي وطبعا
الشيء الاخر يلي قدرت اوصل له هو لما اخذت
الجائزه من الخارجيه الامريكيه قدمت رساله
لميشيل اوباما يعني
بشكل مباشر
و يعني ورساله لاوباما وبتحكي اكثر شيء عن
وضع المعتقلين في السجون ويعني وتحس يعني
انه الاداره الامريكيه على اتخاذ اي اجراء
لحتى بالضغط على النظام السوري لاخراج
المعتقلين ولكن يعني كمان عبس ما ما صار
اي
شيء حمل يعني المجتمع الدولي هذا
التخاذل لانه يعني قدروا يقنعوا تمام ارجو
ان تبقي معنا سنعود اليك لنسمع ل شهادتك
مجددا الان مع المدونات المرئيه هذهه
المره مع المدون النشط الحقوقي المصري
مصطفى عزب الذي تطرق للدور المرجو من
منظمات ح حقوق الانسان بشان ماساه
المعتقلات السوريات
نتابع المنظمه الحقوقيه عليها الا تكتفي
بدور التوثيق والرصد فقط هذا الدور ليس ذا
اثر كبير خاصه في ظل في مواجهه نظام كنظام
بشار الاسد الذي يحتفي ويحتفل بانه يرتكب
هذه الجرائم والانتهاكات ويعتبرها
انتصارات ميدانيه للاسف خاصه في ظل الدعم
الدولي التي تقدمه له بعض الدول وتشارك
معه في هذه الجرائم وتوفر له الدعم الذي
يجعله مستمرا في تلك الجرائم حتى هذه
اللحظه على المنظمات الحقوقيه ان تبذل
جهدا مستمرا في رصد هذه الانتهاكات وفتح
هذا النظام وفتح اجرامه ومخاطبته المجتمع
الدولي وكافه المنظمات الحقوقيه العالميه
والمؤسسات الدوليه لعل هذا الامر يحدث
اثرا حتى ولو على المدى الطويل ابراهيم
عزب سيد فضل تحدث اذا عن دور المطلوب من
المنظمات الحقوقيه لا نريد ان نحملكم اكثر
من طاقتكم لكن ماذا عن مجهود ربما ليس
محلي فقط ماذا عن مجهود ربما وتحالف مع
منظمات دوليه عريقه قد يعتد بين قوسين
برايها هل لديكم خطوات بهذا الخصوص نعم
نحن من 2011 يعني صديقنا الزميل استاذ
وسام انا بتذكر بال 2011 بشهر الثامن نحن
اصدرنا تقرير مشترك معهم حول الاختفاء
القصري وتحدثنا عن 28000 مختفي قصريه خلال
فقط خمسه اشهر تقارير منظمه العفو الدوليه
نحن اغلبها يعني مشاركين فيها وغدا سيصدر
ت وهناك ايضا احاله في بضع مواقع في
التقرير داخل التقرير الى الشبكه السور
لحقوق الانسان وايضا مع هي رايت وش واص
ذلك هناك من يتحدث عن تقصير المنظمات
عفوا الحقوقيه هل نتحدث دائما ربما عن نقص
الدعم السياسي هل امتد الموضوع ايضا
للمنظمات الحقوقيه ام ماذا نعم يعني
المنظمات الحقوقيه دعمها محدود جدا عندما
نتكلم عن عمليه مناصره هي بحاجه الى دعم
كبير جدا لايصال قضيه المعتقلين يجب ان
يكون هناك امر تراكمي ليس فقط تقرير ان
تبني على التقرير تغيب الاراده السياسيه
ايضا لا الاراده السياسيه غائبه لكن انت
يجب ان تقوم بعمليات مناصره في العواصم
العالميه تقوم بمؤتمرات في بريطانيا وفي
فرنسا وتدعي وسائل الاعلام وتقوم با ايفنت
على هامش مجلس حقوق الانسان وعلى الجمعيه
العامه وان يكون دائم موجود حضور دائم
وتكون دائما هناك اكثر من حدث ربما لكن
حدث مخصص لقضيه المعتقلين المعتقلات تقوم
بطباعه بوسترات ضخمه هذا بحاجه الى دعم
كبير جدا انا برايي انه المنظمات الحقوقيه
السوريه يعني اغلبها ونحن ربما من اكبرها
ما عم نلاقي هذا الدعم الموجود وهذا من
داعمين الاصدقاء يعني الشعب السوري طبعا
مقارنه ربما هي اقرب للمفارق الكبيره بين
معامله السجينات في المعتقلات السوريه
وتلك التي تعامل بها اسرائيل المعتقلات
والمعتقلين العرب في سجونها نستعرضها مع
المدونه والنشطه السوريه هدي العويس
نتابع في السجون السوريه المعتقل هو معزول
عزل كامل عن العالم الخارجي وهو غير قادر
على التواصل لا مع منظمات حقوقيه ولا مع
محامي ولا مع اي شخص خارج جدران السجن
بينما نرى في السجون الاسرائيليه
المعتقلين الفلسطينيين هم قادرين على
التواصل مع محامين مع منظمات حقوقيه
ومنظمات دوليه ت على احوالهم وتحصي
اعدادهم وتدافع عنهم ايضا في بعض الاحيان
نعود طبعا مره اخرى للسيده مجد اود ان
اسالك سيده مجد ما الاصعب بعد الافراج
سمعنا احدى الشهدات نقلت قصه سيده رفضت
حتى التوقيع على اخلاء السبيل خوفا من
مواجهه
المجتمع طبعا النساء بالمعتقلات يعني
بالاضافه للتعذيب النفسي يلي كانوا عم
يعانوا منه داخل المعتق للتعذيب الجسدي بس
كان على طول عندهم خوف ورعب
من من خروجهم لبرا انه خصوصا المتزوجات
منهم انه شو را يكون يعني وضعهم بحياتهم
الزوجيه ما بعد خروجهم من المعتقل قد ايه
ممكن الزوج يكون متقبل هذا الشيء وفي
بعضهم طبعا يعني للاسف تم طلاقهم من
ازواجهم بعد ما خرج فقط لانهم هم اعتقلوا
فكان في هي المشكله عند قسم كبير من
النساء او حتى الفتيات يعني بالنسبه
لاهاليهم
فللاسف ما في تقبل
للمجتمع لوضع المعتقله بالق اللوم عليها
وليس
على النظام يل هو ا يلقى اللوم على الضحيه
اكثر مما يلقى على الجلاد او بنفس ربما
المستوى السيده مجد بقي معي اقل من دقيقه
دعيني فقط اتحول بها للسيد الضلم هنا في
الاستوديو انتم كمنظمات حقوقيه هل يمكن
الضغط بهذا الاتجاه لاعاده ادماج هؤلاء
الناجيات لانهن ناجيات من سجون النظام
ربما عن طريق الامم المتحده لاصدار قرارات
ربما تنفيذيه ان صح التعبير بهذا الخصوص
طبعا يعني كما اشارت الصديقه مجد وكما
اشارت الصديقه النوره الاستاذه نوره
والاستاذه مجد انه المجتمع عم يعاملهم انه
هون للاسف الشديد وهن مش ما تسببوا بهذا
امر وهنا سجن حالات حتى عمليات انه اي
يعني عمليات ق قتل قتلوها
اهلها بعد ان خرجت بعضهم من كثر ما ضي
ضيقوا عليها انتحرت يعني في عن سجلنا هي
حالات انتحار هي محدوده عمليات القتل
والانتحار لكن موجوده وهذا مؤشر يعني اما
عن عمليه الادماج فهي من اصعب ما يمكن وهي
بحاجه الى مراكز مختصه وهذا الامر الجانب
النفسي بالازمه السوريه كلها يعني شبه
معدوم
رغم ذلك نحس بالتقصير في هذا الموضوع لان
الكثير يمكن ان يقال بخصوصه اشكرك جزي
الشكر السيد فضل عبد الغني مدير الشبكه
السوريه لحقوق الانسان ضيفنا هنا في
الاستوديو كما نشكر جزيل الشكر السيده مجد
الشوربجي السجينه السوريه كنت معنا من
لبنان رغم كل الشهادات والمعطيات التي
استعرضها فيلم خرجت ولم تعد فان معاناه
المعتقلات السوريات بسجون الاسد هي بكل
تاكيد اكبر وابشع من ذلك بكثير فمع تطور
النزاع واغراق في الدمويه امعن النظام
السوري في التنكيل بعامه النسوى خاصه من
وقعنا في الاعتقال لدى اجهزته القمعيه وفي
كثير من الاحيان كان النظام يبتز بسلامته
وشرفه المعارضه كي يمنعها من التقدم
ميدانيا في سبيل بقاء الاسد مستويا على
عرش الحكم في بلاد الشام يهون كل شيء عنده
بما في ذلك الانتهاكات الفظيعه لحقوق
المعتقلات السوريه والنيل من شرف بعضهن
انتهت حلقه اليوم موعدنا الاثنين المقبل
مع بقيه لقصه اخرى السلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم
ت
ا